Speaker 1: . Hey, David, with all of the talk
of vaccine passports, I'm wondering, is a
vaccine passport even really a controversial
thing?
So, no, the answer is no.
I mean, listen, the term vaccine passport
is now being used.
But what we're really talking about is to
do certain things.
Vaccination has been required for a very long
time.
We're now talking about adding an additional
vaccination.
But let's break it down to travel to other
countries.
There have been vaccination requirements for
decades.
There are countries in South America and in
Africa where you need a yellow fever vaccine
to go.
You need to show proof of yellow fever vaccination
to go to Saudi Arabia.
I don't know if it's at any time or during
the Hajj.
You need to show proof of a meningococcal
vaccine.
There's a list.
Just look at mandatory vaccine travel requirements.
So there's really no difference in another
country saying.
Imagine France, there's two things France
might do, France could say everybody who lives
in France must be vaccinated.
That would be government forcing a vaccination
on people.
That's not going to happen, France could say,
to travel here from another country, non French,
anybody who's not who doesn't have a citizenship.
Right.
To be in France.
We require the covid-19 vaccine.
They could do that.
That wouldn't be new.
That wouldn't be controversial.
It would only be new as it applies specifically
to the coronavirus vaccine.
We are seeing more and more colleges say to
be on campus in the fall.
Students will have to be vaccinated.
This is not new.
This is not controversial.
Don Jr has been tweeting about this as if
it's some kind of dystopian communist authoritarian
nightmare.
I know it makes no sense.
His kids go to schools that require certain
vaccinations.
And what some schools are doing is they are
choosing what is the list of required vaccinations
to come to this school.
You don't have to go to that school now.
Let's get to so now that we realize that what
we're talking about is actually not new or
particularly controversial, let's go to what
is being sometimes implied by the term vaccine
passport.
One thing that's being implied is the U.S.
government will require you to have a vaccine.
It's not going to happen, just not going to
happen.
And it's a straw man.
This is sort of like when someone says, hey,
let's do universal background checks and the
right says they're coming for the Second Amendment,
they're going to get rid of the Second Amendment.
No, that's not what's happening now.
It's not what's happening at all.
There is not going to be mandatory U.S. government.
I can't speak for every other country.
There may be some other authoritarian countries
that will mandate covid vaccination.
The U.S. is not going to mandate covid vaccination.
What you what you may see is different businesses
say we will require vaccination.
If you want to do business with us at a certain
point, you may see an airline say we are beyond
the period of requiring a test.
At this point.
If you want to fly with us, you need a vaccine.
You may see certain sports teams or leagues
say if you want to come after a certain date,
we're going to wait until the vaccine has
been open to everyone for three months after
that point, which would be, I guess, July
19th.
If you want to come to a game at our stadium,
you need to be vaccinated.
I don't think it will be super common, but
that would be completely within the rights
of businesses to do.
And a lot of the right wingers opposing that
are the same people that for twenty years
or 10 years or five years have been saying
businesses should be able to do whatever they
want as long as it's not illegal.
It's not illegal to require vaccine.
They will also there's another talking point
floating around, which is they are violating
Hypatia because they are requiring you to
share medical information.
This is a completely ridiculous interpretation
of what hip hop is.
Hipper is something that medical professionals
are bound by.
The business isn't forcing you to reveal.
First of all, hip doesn't apply because it's
you, not a doctor's office that would be sharing
vaccination information.
Number two, you're not even being required
to do it.
It's here is what we require if you, as a
participant in the market, choose to do business
with us.
Terrible, terrible argument.
Now, are there arguments against vaccine requirements
generally?
This isn't just about covid.
Sure, sure.
You know, if you have a situation where there's
really inequitable access to a vaccine, you
could have a situation where what you are
saying is the poor part of the world can't
come to our country if we put in a vaccine
mandate.
And that's something that you could deal with
a friend.
Imagine in the imaginary friends vaccine mandate,
France might say.
To come to our country, if you're not a French
national, of course, if you are in a country.
Where X percent of the population has already
been vaccinated, then you need a vaccine,
we will offer a test and quarantine exemption
for people from countries that have not yet
reached 50 percent.
You could figure that out.
That's something that you could figure out.
What about people who can't get the vaccine
because of a condition that they have where
they are not able to get vaccinated?
OK, that that's a now we're talking about
a practical issue that we can deal with.
Can you get a medical exemption from a vaccine
requirement that's also not new?
That's something that's been around for a
very long time.
What countries can choose not to offer, though,
are exemptions for so-called religious beliefs,
and that would be up to each, each and every
country to decide.
So long story short, vaccine requirements
for travel, not new vaccine requirements for
schools, not new.
The government of the U.S. is not going to
force people to be vaccinated.
And beyond that, we're talking about people
participating in markets don't like the rule
that a business has.
Don't do business with them.
No problem whatsoever.